attention series station we demand the
immediate and unconditional surrender of
all free navy forces this feels like a
trap and we're in it now
miss them up
take the shot
hey guys pete here this is going to be
an extremely short expanse video
about those extremely short teasers you
just watched i'm not complaining though
because it's more than we got last
season and these are both pretty
interesting i talked about this week's
x-ray mini episode zenobia in the stream
i did yesterday but i'll touch on that a
little here too in case you missed that
for spoilers i'm just going to be
talking about what you see here and can
make out from the clips i mentioned but
if for some reason you've changed your
mind this is your chance to leave and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
the it's getting real on siri station
clip brings back a character we haven't
seen since season three back then she
was the mcrn captain on the hammurabi i
went back to revisit her scenes earlier
from season 3 episode 5 triple point and
ended up getting sucked in and watched
the entire episode so many great moments
in that one you had amos and prax naomi
apologizing to holden for how she went
about giving the proto-molecule to fred
and telling him about philip admiral
wynne shooting souther and then blowing
up the un ship the jimenez jul pierre
mao deciding to turn mei into a hybrid
after katoa got too far along to
communicate bobby being full-on obsessed
about fighting a hybrid one-on-one and
avasarala trying to get holden to bring
back a proto-molecule sample for earth
it's an all-timer episode and captain
carino played a crucial role that made a
lasting impression she got the intel
that avasarala sent with sinopoly who
you might remember tried to retake the
rossi and failed with his crew after
they were saved by them and corrino had
to make a decision that could have got
her in trouble for treason if things
went wrong she did as abba sorella asked
and got the message that proved the war
was illegal to souther who then led a
short-lived mutiny to try to remove wind
then when the unn ships started shooting
at each other she sat back instead of
engaging which turned out to be the
right decision so a memorable character
and here it looks like she's on the
xenobia talking about the situation on
series with abasarala it does look like
marco was correct when he thought they
might want to take it back after they
were able to redeploy their fleets
there's a shot of an mcrn ship docking
and an announcement calling for the
immediate and unconditional surrender of
all free navy forces there are troops
coming into the station but it doesn't
look like they encounter any resistance
at all instead they turn a corner and
sort of find a crowd of people that all
seem compliant with cendrani being the
only recognizable face this is followed
by carino saying this feels like a trap
and avasarala acknowledging that they're
now in it there's not much more to say
about this there is a shot of monica
wearing some protective gear that we saw
her wearing in the preseason trailers
and of course there's no sign of marco
who in the second teaser we see is on
the pillar getting ready to engage in
battle this one i can't say as much
about but it was posted with the
question can philip prove himself to
marco which sort of feels like a trick
question in a way but they are sitting
side by side behind the weapons controls
on the pela they're looking at a ship
that could look kind of familiar if you
look at it closely and philip tells his
father that they have missile lock
meaning they can take a shot which marco
tells him to do considering that they're
on the opposite sides of each other in
this war you could look at this
hypothetical of what would philip do if
he found himself in a situation where he
might have to kill his own mother those
are the kind of tough decisions you have
to make in war sometimes especially when
your parents are fighting on opposite
sides very close to the action it's
something to think about and the last
thing to talk about today is the second
one ship episode that was titled zenobia
this week's installment was a touching
story where we learned that not only
does avasarala sleep like a vampire but
that this war is taking a toll on her
health and a well-timed message from her
granddaughter who's starting a garden to
help to contribute to the effort
recharged her and got her back out there
and ready to continue the fight it was a
nice setup and a great little solo
performance and i had more than a few
comments asking if it was all starting
to feel like they might be setting up an
end for the character the health stuff
stands out right away but i think it's
related mostly to stress and exhaustion
and she did contact the doctor about
medication i did make a video before the
season started because i had been
thinking that they might kill somebody
off and i also mentioned in my review
that there were a few places where i had
that feeling in the season itself so i
could see where that idea is coming from
but i was also kind of worried when i
saw that avasarala was going to be out
in space rather than on luna when the
first trailer came out the one thing
that stood out to me beyond that was
that she mentioned the doctrine of one
ship i'm curious to see how they connect
these all together using that i talked
about this in my preview video last week
and how it was introduced to us through
michiopaw and the books and it is a
belter thing so having an earther talk
about it is interesting so we'll see
where they go and i think that's about
all i needed to say so i'll leave it
there let me know in the comments what
you thought about the teasers and what
you're hoping to see in the next episode
i'll drop my recap on friday and i do
think that now that i've tested it out
and can make some tweaks i think i'll be
doing another stream after this episode
comes out although the schedule's a
little up in the air with the holidays
so check back for that please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon